good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy
hump day it is wednesday we are s
not that close but we're almost there
we're getting we're getting over the
hump
i know but you know it's so early like
hopefully when you guys are listening to
this episode like
the majority of humpty's behind you but
for us we're at the bottom of the hill
like it's right in front of us
we're at like the top of the hill a
little more hill about to go downhill
usually this top of the hill is easier
because you are able to hum someone you
love
but there are no puppers here today i
almost brought bruno today i did i was
like today's gonna be the day
but he had such a good day yesterday on
his schedule like i don't want to jinx
anything but
no everything was outside or on the mat
and so i was like i need to replicate i
need to get him into this groove so i
didn't want to disturb his piece
by bringing him here today i know he
would have had an accident on this
carpet because it looks like a big
wee-wee pad
so i was like no bruce today but
maybe tomorrow you know there's always
tomorrow well the reason why the hump
himself
theo is not here today is because i was
obviously going to bring him as i do
every day most days
but i have right after this to head to
the studio for
like six hours to start recording my
audiobook and so i couldn't bring theo
to that so like it was just to ruin my
schedule
but i'm very excited to get started on
my audiobook you can have pre-order it
link in my bio on instagram or girl with
no job.com book
right so even though theo isn't here
don't get confused it is still hot okay
it can be confusing it can be and it's
also veterans day so we want to thank
all of our service men and women women
active service members
former service members we thank you we
appreciate you
and we salute you we really do thank you
we are the land of the free because of
the brave um
so i've kind of been on this like
journey in my living room i told you
like i'm just watching so much stuff
and i started a show last night that i
just i think it bears discussion
okay it's only three episodes in
actually the fourth one aired last night
but i didn't watch it it's called a
teacher
i heard about it on your instagram it's
on fx so it's like fx is obviously just
putting out like content with filthy
rich i also watch the new episode of
filthy rich filthy rich is on fox can be
confusing because there's just an o
yeah i wonder if a teacher's on fox or
fx
i don't know i feel like it's on fx
because i haven't heard of it and it's a
little dirty
fx is a little more niche so the premise
is kate mara
she's you know a beautiful young girl
yes she's like a young teacher so she's
like in her you know
lower 30s oh she's the teacher yes and
the guy the kid from love simon
he's just like that cutie okay he plays
the high school senior
and it's obviously about this you know
tawdrid love affair
um i do believe that like the affair has
already started in the show so like i
believe they get caught and like the
police like
the trial is more of the show but
wow it's really problematic like i hate
to be like such a weenie but
it's really really problematic the show
i'm really shocked that like this got
greenlit because
they are very much like romanticizing
and glamorizing this relationship where
like at times you find yourself like
rooting for them even though it's like
pedophilia it's grooming
and they do start and end every show
with like a screen that has resources
for people like if you or someone you
know needs help
with grooming or whatever go to
teacherresources.org but like
it's so bizarre because it's so it's not
at least not yet it's not being painted
out to be like a wrong
relationship it's they're making it out
to be like love it's
so bizarre jackie and it's you feel so
dirty watching it
but it's also like kind of good you know
well that actually reminds me about this
book that we read for the redheads
called my dark vanessa and it's a very
similar situation
it's a male teacher and he's like in his
40s i can envision the actors that
you're talking about and they do
look more similar in age than the book
that we read but
it is it's extremely disturbing yeah and
but i think
that i don't know where your series is
going to lead you but i think
it's going to ultimately make a very
important point and
the what you perceive as the glamorizing
of
it right now might just be what they're
trying to show you as
other people like normalize yeah maybe
you know yeah
yeah no i mean i'll see where it goes
like i definitely really like it it's
just like i just wasn't expecting to
like
to just watch that yesterday do you know
what i mean yeah no i
i totally understand i'm jealous that
you
got to watch some premium content
because i weirdly had like the busiest
day ever yesterday
i was watching the bachelor until
midnight like that's how my day just got
so pushed back
i went to the live method to work on
myself at for the first time in like a
few months and it was really
tough but they're doing a great job over
there and they have this machine that
like
tells your body composition that's scary
no no
it was so depressing for me like
what has happened to my body composition
over the last eight months
is a travesty a true travesty
and i was glad to be back i'm definitely
feeling motivated then
dana came over she and i did a podcast
for the patreon like about our
friendship
you know going down memory lane talking
about she's been a coveted bride so
she's talking about her experience and
honestly
it was so much fun it was so funny we
did a podcast once before and it got
such great reviews the episode will go
up today i'm so excited for you guys to
hear it because like i loved it so much
and i don't know if it was just because
like we i was hanging out with myself
yeah no and we just like think we're
funny but
it was hysterical so i'm really excited
for you guys to hear that and so my yeah
my night just got like backed up backed
up bruno
was being sweets all day was it just me
or was the episode of the bachelorette
five hours long it was so long and we
will get to it in our tv recap segment
but i just
i just want to put it out there like
we're technically episode one we've like
reset
and i'm i'm fatigued that is five hours
of my life i'll never get back
yeah i mean it was only two hours but i
know what you mean
there's no proof that it was only two
hours like i was it wouldn't end
every time i went to like go to the next
commercial like skip commercials
my tracker was like a quarter of the way
through i know it was
real i watched it live and it was just
it was very real you know
like it was also when i don't watch live
i like can also be on instagram because
yeah snatchers posting memes
check her out it's the snatcher and i
don't want to like get a spoiler
yeah i also don't want to be told that
or persuaded on what to think so that's
why i don't check out the means
like i can't watch my sister's stories
and like that hurts i miss my sister
no also the bachelor is like the perfect
show where like you must be on your
phone at the same time like it is not
titillating enough
to watch on its own yeah um i have ton
of notes from the recap
so we will definitely get into that and
now we're very much in after dale
yeah no well not not that much because
he was on our screens last night again
yeah next week after day um and we also
have dear toasters today which is our
advice segment
so we will be doing that in the
bachelorette recap after the past five
stories
and we have some great stories today so
i think we could jump right in if ever
that's cool with everyone if that's cool
it's an extremely hasty jumping
is it extremely no no no i think it's
been a number of minutes it's been a
number of minutes
so without further ado these are the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and yes jackie but we have a brand new
sponsor today that is so
pertinent to every toaster who's ever
existed i love a bns
usual wines are the wines for the modern
drinker here's
the great thing about modern wines each
bottle i'm sorry usual ones
each bottle is 6.3 ounces so it's
basically a heavy pour or about a glass
and a half of wine
so no more putting wine down the sink
when you don't want to finish the bottle
because of the single serve format and
the bottle design
usual wines are always fresh no more
flat bubbly or stale rose
the wines are low carb and have zero
grams of sugar usual has a red blend a
rose and a sparkling white wine called
brut they also have a limited production
beer
rose just for the summer usual wines are
made from world-class american
viticultural areas in california like
napa sonoma santa barbara
and they're made with minimal
intervention zero sugar and zero
additives
and yes all grapes have sugar but usual
wines are produced using natural
sustainable grapes
harvested every fall the grapes are
picked at an optimal ripeness to ensure
all sugar will be fermented completely
until the wines are dry with no residual
sugar
they also are releasing a new holiday
product in november it's called usual
reserve
this is their most special wine yet just
in time for the holidays hailing from
one of the most celebrated plots of land
in all of napa
this is cabernet sauvignon in
concentration
and it's concentrated and rich with just
enough grip
if you want to gift it to someone
special or keep it all for yourself for
the holidays
that's your business usual wines doesn't
judge neither do we if you want to check
out
all of their wines and their fabulous
products go to their website
www.usualwines.com and if you're looking
for eight dollars off your first
order you can use code toast where you
can try your first glass on us
so that's usualwines.com our discount
code is toast
for eight dollars off your first order
and just check it out i mean the
holidays
the holidays can be a difficult time
make sure to have wine on standby
every once in a while an extremely
toasty sponsor comes no and that's it
and that's it i mean the whole thing
with like having to cut your cork in
half and like shoving it back in the
bottle just so we can sit in the fridge
for a month and like you never use it
and like maybe you'll use it when you're
cooking it's just so silly the fact
like this brand just being 6.3 ounce
bottle bottles like a genius is solving
a problem
yeah and that's what they say on shark
tank like do not come into the tank if
you're not solving a problem
okay first story about one of our
favorite guys we haven't had an
opportunity to talk about in a
pretty good amount of time jason momoa
reveals he was completely
in debt after being killed off of game
of thrones yes
i saw this he did a very sexy photo
shoot in this interview
with in style the aquaman star recalled
how he struggled to pay the bills after
his character khal drogo
was killed off of game of thrones in
2011. game of thrones is arguably the
most successful tv show of the past
decade
it smashed an emmy's record by earning
32 nominations for its final run
the most ever for a single season at the
2019 emmys game of thrones took home the
prize for outstanding drama series and
won 11 more trophies
however season one actor jason momoa
didn't benefit much from the initial
game of thrones boom
this week he revealed that his quick
stint is called drogo did not grant him
the fame and fortune that his co-stars
would go on to experience
the hbo fantasy fantasy series hailed as
one of the best
book to tv adaptations skyrocketed the
careers of its stars sophie turner macy
williams emilia clark and kit harrington
yet jason momoa told in style i mean we
were starving after game of thrones i
couldn't get work it's very challenging
when you have babies and you're
completely in debt
he said that it wasn't until um his
financial situation only improved about
five years later
once he was cast as aquaman in a string
of films based on the dc comics
so wait when he said we were starving he
was with lisa bennett
and they had babies but doesn't she have
tons of money
cosby show yeah i'm sure like
she but you know he was out of work
actor
you know no but it is very interesting
like that call like
jason mamoa came from culture ago khal
drogo was this iconic character but if
you watch the show he was legit in four
episodes
and although he left it lasting mark
like in our hearts not really on the
television show because he was barely in
it and then he got killed so
yeah it it's weird that this huge career
came from that when like he was barely
on the show no i mean
and also he was just one of those deaths
that it's like not only is this so hard
for the viewers you know because
this is one of our favorite characters
now but then you do have to think about
the actor who only got like
one season role in that star biggest
show of all time right like imagine
being ned stark and imagine getting that
part and being like
i'm the patriarch of the biggest family
on the biggest this is going to be the
biggest show and like it's
literally centered around me i am the
moral compass of the show i am i think
you will become a billionaire final
spoiler alert penultimate episode season
one i'm gone head
guillotine out of here yeah no it's back
to the audition process for me
totally no totally
and i actually never really thought
about that with jason momoa i just think
he's so like extraordinary looking and
talented
that like he was never not going to
become a star but you do have to think
about those
there's the time in between yeah game of
thrones and aquaman i also think we
watched season one
of game of thrones like two years after
it was released right and there was this
five-year
lull for him he says so like by the time
we heard about aquaman it just like
seemed like
that was a hops given a jump not a
five-year period where he was struggling
yeah also this is totally unrelated but
after the bachelorette last night
i know you probably watch it because you
didn't get done until midnight but i got
done at 10 o'clock
they had this road to the cma's thing
hosted by um like reba
and darius rucker and i actually thought
it was really interesting because they
had like a little round table with
darius rucker jimmy allen ashley mcbride
and i'm so sorry i don't know the fourth
guy's name i had literally never heard
of him and like i'm country music's
biggest fan and
i just and it was country music's second
biggest night yeah and i i
i literally never said it was the night
before country music's biggest night
i've never seen this man i apologize to
this man i have no idea who this man is
i'm sorry tim
so they were talking about how um this
has been super tough for them like
mostly because they have like
crew and bands who like they can't pay
because they're not making shows
and a lot of them really opened up about
what they did like darius rucker was
like
i paid my band for as long as i could
but like you have no money coming in
like you can't
keep sending money out and jimmy allen
like he literally made me cry you know
what he did
he's like i just went to the bank and i
got the biggest loan i could and they
gave me 45 years to pay back and i'm
still paying my entire band and crew
like it was
i couldn't believe like and that's like
not something he was like bragging about
like he didn't read it in people
magazine but they were just talking
openly about like how difficult it's
been for like the band who's been with
them forever to like not
be able to make money during cobin and
like how it's just been a really
difficult time for country music not for
like the major celebrities but for like
all the people that make country music
happen
yeah crew truck drivers but then also
for those bigger players like i'm
it sounds like they have this like sense
of guilt that they can't you know
they have a lot of people that rely on
them right that's what jimmy allen said
he's like if the music never came back
like i would be okay
like but my career like they have
families kids wives and it was just like
it was really interesting conversation
about like the music industry about how
like
no one's worried about celebrities like
they're gonna be fine but
there's so many people underneath a
celebrity that like get that get the
celebrity
to the stage right and i thought it was
a really well done conversation they
also talked a lot about just like
how covid and the black lives matter
movement has impacted country music
and it was just a very i don't know if
they do that every year but it was a
really well done like little montage
that sounds really good it was excellent
robin roberts no not robin roberts
yeah robin roberts she uh hosted it oh
wow well the cmas are on tonight so i
look forward to that
and also i'm outside of salt lake city
and real housewives of orange county but
i was going to say one more thing about
what you were just saying
let's see oh i was just going to say
whenever concerts come back i'm going to
one every single night
same well just to support also do you
know what i did last night
i watched our cma red carpet from which
year
last year okay that's like i think last
year's actually which year do you think
it was the best
i think two years ago where i showed my
arm i think so too it was just like
super casual
and i think we did a really good job but
i also think i think we do a great job
every year me too
i would actually we had the best spot
our first year
yes accidentally accidentally someone
messed up yeah
and but last year we had like the most
street cred we've ever had but also last
year we had the worst spot on the red
carpet
right but last year i think i looked my
best because the year before i guess for
some reason like mentally i was just
like not feeling myself so i wore like
long sleeves
and um i don't think that i needed to
well i watched it
and you know what like i don't really
like to watch myself i like
i obviously watch my comedy special
because like i needed to edit it and
stuff
but um i just don't really like to watch
myself because i'm very critical and i
deserve it because i was being an animal
at the cma where it's like
literally talking so fast talking over
everyone hugging people when they did
not want to be hugged like
i was an animal so like now i'm just
like really motivated to get back to the
cma so i can wrong all my rights so you
can remedy the situation
oh no sorry right all my wrongs okay
next story some interesting um streaming
numbers news that just like isn't making
sense to me okay
adam sandler's new movie hubie halloween
have you ever heard of it
you haven't heard of it no one has
literally spent all my time on netflix i
had um i don't know what to call it the
distinct displeasure
of watching the movie what yeah i watch
it because so not like you zack really
wanted to watch it
and i was like i didn't have a better
suggestion right so i was like huey
halloween it is for us
compromise you guys that's marriage and
it was like you know honest
it's weird the movie stunk yeah but the
end of it the message and i don't
i don't want to spoil the end because i
actually like liked how it ended okay
but i'm
literally never going to watch it so
please spoil it okay if you're gonna
watch it
don't listen to this i'll i'll give you
a wave when i'm done spoiling it
so basically hubie halloween he's like
this town joke
he loves halloween and every halloween
they live in salem massachusetts so
halloween is like
extra balls to the wall but every
halloween the entire town plays pranks
on him like mean pranks throw stuff at
him on his bicycle
and all he wants to do is like make
halloween the best for everyone but like
he's literally getting bullied
from the kids from the adults from his
peers he's lived in the town his whole
life
and his whole life they've bullied him
on halloween and
someone is taking revenge on his behalf
on halloween like literally like
snatching people
you know we don't know where they go the
whole movie they just disappear and it's
like who is doing all of this
and it's unclear that they're doing it
in defense of huby it just seems like
there's like a
a witch going around in salem
no it doesn't feel like a do-gooder it's
like who's the kidnapper like there's
and also there was like an escape from
um mental institution so you think it's
that person
anyways at the end of the movie it turns
out that it was hubey's mom
who was doing all of these things to
show uh to teach all these people a
lesson like you're so mean to my son
like stop stop being so mean to me he's
a good person yeah he only wants the
best for this town she like brought them
all to her
her backyard to like yell at them for me
he means it's
actually so funny and like i actually
liked how it ended just like his mom
taking up for him like wasn't gonna
stand for him to like be bullied on
another halloween
so i liked how it ended oh my that's so
funny that
doesn't sound like anything i would
literally ever watch but what's the
oh we're done spoilers done spoilers
that movie is the most popular netflix
film of 2020
of all the time people have spent on
netflix this year
that movie is the most popular film well
now let me ask a few questions
is it the most popular netflix original
movie
probably let's say let's just go with
netflix original sure
okay and so what other netflix originals
have there been the kissing booth too
to all the boys they loved before too
what else
i feel like there are so many and a lot
of them are action movies and we don't
watch them
i guess you know what this isn't like
that surprising to me it is surprising
just because i haven't seen any like
marketing for it so i don't know how
many
people would know about it and it hasn't
popped up on my home screen but i feel
like
adam sandler has a huge audience of
people his age but then all of his
movies are like very kid-friendly was it
a child-friendly movie
yes yeah so this actually makes like a
little bit of sense but
it's only crazy that like i literally
have never heard of this movie in my
entire life and like
all i do is sit at home on the netflix
app right and as you guys know he has
this huge deal with netflix
we got uh murder mystery which i liked
sandy wexler couldn't get through the
do-over the ridiculous six
he has more movies coming out with
netflix and like when i saw this movie i
was like
ooh but like i actually can't believe
that that is like it's so successful
i'm like absolutely shook that of all
the movies that you just named i've
never seen one of them you saw murder
mystery jennifer aniston no
no i know what it is i never saw it oh i
didn't mind it i just
i don't know why i actually really
really like adam sandler
as everything except an actor do you
know what i mean like i think he's a
really funny comedian i love him as a
celebrity
but i i never saw just go with it
i never saw um
the one with chris rock grown-ups oh
yeah
i never i i did see click and spanglish
both of which are
[ __ ] amazing brilliant genius
spectacular throw it in a blender give
birth to it
did you see uncut gems nope no and i
didn't hear
i heard like i think critics gave it
good reviews
my peers gave it bad reviews i trust my
peers over critics
literally any day yeah so yeah i just
thought that was an interesting factoid
yeah and it says a lot about like our
what we're up to what we're up to we're
just looking for things for our kids to
watch so we can go back to the kitchen
and have more usual wine
yeah literally okay next story some
exciting news i think christina aguilera
apparently
is joining jay-z's rock nation
interesting like
the record label yes so there's been no
official announcement yet but the
beautiful singer's bio has appeared on
the agency's website
she'll be in the coveted company of
rihanna j cole alicia keys and meek mill
so interesting her last album was
released in 2018 so i think we can
expect some sort of announcement soon
and i just think like
this is like a good move for her and
also maybe signals new music from
christine miss christine aguilera i mean
i don't know if i were her like i
wouldn't
be putting out music because people
don't respect like
the work that she does no seriously
because they never respected lotus yeah
i would never give them anything else i
wouldn't give him a drop of my time
no energy spirituality none of that but
girl's got to eat so i'm sure she does
have to release the music
and this is very interesting i feel like
roc nation it's actually been very cool
to be like a fan of pop culture for the
last like
10 years and see roc nation go from like
being a startup to like being like
literally a billion dollar company yeah
for sure um beyonce is that rock nation
obviously right
i'm not sure i feel like she's not she
would columbia she would have been on
that short list i just read
right but isn't it jay-z's company yeah
i don't know how i don't know how you
mix business and pleasure too also she
had been managed by the legendary irving
azoff who we know as a family friend of
the kardashians
always comes back to our girls always
comes back it literally all of hollywood
in one way or another whether it be like
through business or family
can be drawn into that kardashian
jenner like david foster family tree
mm-hmm like that is the center of
hollywood 100 it's the birthplace of
hollywood and everything else exists
from the crowds thank you the roots are
there the jenner the kardashian roots
and the oj and then linda thompson like
it's all just connected
to the kardashians totally so some
exciting news for christina we haven't
spoken about her
this is just a day of extremely random
stories and then yeah for it
can i just say something i really love
about christina even though she's like
kind of been like irrelevant you could
say
she's on the voice sometimes not anymore
kelly clarkson replaced her but she was
i feel like the voice is kind of like a
revolving door like you might be out one
season but you're back the next sort of
thing
yeah but i also don't watch so tell me
if i'm wrong yeah no you're right i mean
forever it was just the four
cielo green adam levine blake shelton
and
christina yeah yeah and then she was
gone and she was gone for good and then
they like threw miley in there for a
minute but i don't know if she was well
received
now i think they're going on second
season not changing anyone kelly
clarkson john legend blake shelton
and gwen stefani gwen stefani yeah
because i just saw a commercial that's
like gwen is back so it's like the door
swung again you know
oh maybe yeah yeah because she was on
and then she wasn't and
was on and she did great so i feel like
yeah it's never like you're gone for
good it's like they just switch it up
honestly i can't believe that blake
shelton has literally it's like out of
all of them the one who's never left
he's very good
and adam levine he's not on anymore oh
bye so just blake shelton like he's
the mainstay yeah he put that franchise
on his back
if you like the voice dana and i and one
of our stories that we tell we've told
it before i can't believe
someone was like tell this story again i
was like i can't believe that you guys
even know the story i can't believe i
told it because it's like so
embarrassing
and it relates back to the voice in a
really funny way so make sure to check
it out make sure to check it out i'll
get that episode up for you guys as soon
as possible what i was going to say
about christina aguilera is that even
though she's been like low-key for a
while i love how much she's like a fan
of pop culture like she invited bethany
and a bunch of housewives to her
birthday party
when kylie dressed as her for halloween
kylie got invited to her birthday party
she goes on watch robin's live i think
she watches a lot of bravo and i just
like
i love a celebrity who like enjoys has
similar interests
to me agreed okay this next story is
really exciting news for me
um and probably for a lot of you
mcdonald's is unveiling its own meatless
burger the mick
plant a year after the beyond meat taste
test
am i delusional or did we already report
on this because literally
i saw this yesterday and i'm like we
reported on this when we were back in
our pink studio like i know it
maybe we reported on this beyond meat
test but i've never
i've never said the word mcplant before
okay really then tell me why when we
were driving
with ben this summer and
we went to a mcdonald's and we asked if
they had a plant-based burger because we
like
it's been in our brain i'm telling you
like yeah no of course then they said no
and then we went to burger king i just
thought like maybe they didn't have it
at that one yes i think that there have
been some mcdonald's that carried some
of this beyond me because they did a
test and i think that's what we reported
on it's coming back to me now in a few
cities
they tested beyond meat burgers and i
guess it went well and why did it take
so long
burger king rolled them out in a day no
every single
has meatless options and mcdonald's is
honestly behind the curve which is crazy
because
in every other sense they've always been
like the leading fast food chain like
their marketing's always better they're
just like they're just
the supreme yeah so they're really a
little too late
if you're going to ask me well um
i'm selfishly glad because it's like
more plant-based options for for
us like kosher queens vegetarian
plant-based vegan et cetera i don't know
and
because we haven't filmed our video yet
of us doing all these different
fast food taste tests and now we can get
more stuff at mcdonald's when is it
gonna be rolled out
okay here's the deets the big mac or mc
plant that will soon be
the two options consumers in line at
mcdonald's will have for their latest
high calorie fast food dinner
mean wait high calorie
i mean i guess it's not locally i know
but it's still a burger
how many calories does grass have no but
what about the burger i mean the bun
it's just like whatever and then you get
the fries yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
golden arch has said monday it has
developed a plant-based patty it will
dub the mcplant a mcdonald's
spokesperson tells yahoo finance the
mcplan will be put into test in 2021
on a market by market basis so it sounds
like you know nothing's happening for us
until 2021.
can i say something a little
controversial so i guess the video will
have to wait until 2021 oh that's true
i think that works for schedule um yeah
i don't like the name
mcplant like it doesn't like mcchicken
just rolls off the tongue like
big mac like you know like mcplant like
it just
it doesn't work for me i think it should
have been like mcveg i don't know like
they could have come up with something
but uh i like make veg and they should
make a
veggie burger it's not a veggie burger
but it's not a veggie burger i actually
like milk plants no i think it's funny
it's too many like continents mcplant
like do you know what i mean
yeah but i think i think you should say
like that mcplant
if you're if you extend the a it rolls
off the tongue
it doesn't work for me i'm gonna come up
with a better option and i will pitch it
like
i'm gonna go to the window and be like
hi um can i get a mcplon
you know what it really is because it's
so gross it's a mcnasty
that's so mean her phone hurtful
i'm sorry i didn't mean to yucky i'm
sure they had like countless hours of
meetings workshops brainstorms about
this name and so
you're definitely hurting someone's
feelings and i'm sure they thought of
everything and like
just know that mcplant was the best they
could do but do you think it would be a
day at the episode an episode of the
morning joseph i didn't hurt someone's
feelings no and or if you didn't yuck
someone's yums
yes so true i'm the queen of yucking
gums just because honestly like
everything is yuck
to you yeah and everything is yum to me
fifth and final story a little veteran's
day um
story some of our favorite celebs who
have served in the military
jax taylor oh navy that he's not
included on this people magazine but i
just i think it's important that people
don't forget that like
when i first read that he he got
profiled by complex magazine at the
height of phantom from roles
and they said he was in the navy and i
was like what like that's crazy you just
you just forget like they had lies
before vanderpump rule sorry keep 100
so here are some stars who have served
in the military one tom selleck
of course he has like because would he
be my dream man like of course of course
that mustache was
in korea or something b arthur from
golden girls
oh wow morgan freeman wow
hugh hefner what adam driver
what yep you won uh he joined the marine
shortly after september 11th
ah how old was he um he was 17.
oh my goodness tony bennett
i don't know why it's just like after a
certain age it's like of course you were
in the military
right yeah so i'm not shocked by tony
bennett rob riggle
oh i love robergill he's a cutie he is a
cutie and those kfc commercials are
pretty good
johnny cash okay it makes sense clint
eastwood
of course elvis presley yes makes sense
iced tea
iced tea you mean tutuola yup he joined
the army's 25th infantry division after
high school
wow that's so interesting robin quivers
from the howard stern show
no way she was a nurse in the air force
rising to the rank of captain this is so
interesting isn't this interesting
jimi hendrix okay humphrey bogart
i'm gonna age myself i don't know who
that is um he's but
the name is definitely like old-timey
like gone with the wind vibes but
yeah yeah can't put a face to the name
chuck norris
i think i know who that is yeah yeah
she's like red hair yeah yeah yeah
josh ball he's from dodgeball jimmy
stewart he's from it's a wonderful life
in vertigo i think
oh yes of course vertigo how can i
forget james earl jones
i definitely know him he's got a great
voice yeah he's the voice of the lion
guard yes he was in the lion king and he
voiced um
darth vader in star wars got it okay
yeah so that's
people's list well i think the most
shocking of all of that is adam driver
and ice-t
because they're the most contemporary
yeah yeah some of the older
folks have been drafted right but they
they enlisted
i can't believe they excluded jax taylor
i feel like some like that list could
definitely i'm sure there are more just
depends like what you consider like a
big star
oh like jack taylor on the same list as
elvis presley like i'm not sure yeah i
do think that might not
add up for some people right like i
didn't see any other reality stars
it's such a shame yeah um that was a
great article
and i didn't know most of that just a
fun way to celebrate veteran's day
so let's do our bachelorette recap which
is brought to you by
legacy box love legacy box guys please
listen up because
this is one of those brands where it's
like what was the legacy box code
because like
when you need it you can't remember it
so legacy box is that fabulous service
that takes all of your old like home
movies whether on there on like vcr or
vhs like different tapes
you throw it in a box and they digitally
uh copy them for you so you can get it
back on like a usb
drive or on the cloud and it's literally
the most brilliant thing and it's a
perfect holiday gift
it is and we're getting closer to the
holidays so listen up if you're thinking
of a gift for someone that you love and
you can't really think of anything this
will mean
so much to them legacy box is the way
for you to easily and affordably
digitally preserve your past
the process from start to finish is so
easy you pack and send your items their
team digitizes everything by hand and
then you enjoy
you'll get back perfectly preserved
digital copies on a thumb drive dvd or
the cloud
and you can be ready to watch and share
them in a matter of minutes
everything is digitized by hand at their
secure 8 acre digitizing campus
they use premier scanners and playback
decks to ensure each memory is mastered
to the highest quality plus they'll keep
you up to date with regular emails about
the digitizing process and when you can
expect your tapes back
legacy box is the world's largest
digitizer of home movies and photos and
they have helped
over 850 000 families digitally preserve
the past
so if you want to get started future
proof proofing your memories today so
you can gather the family and begin the
trip down memory lane
go to legacy box dot com slash toast to
get an incredible 40
off your first order buy today to take
advantage of this exclusive offer and
you can just send it in when you're
ready you don't have to send it now but
if you want to get the offer
go to legacybox.com toast and save 40
while supplies last love it really such
a great
such a great gift idea or gift yourself
give yourself the gift
of memories okay so here are my
bachelorette notes
um we started this episode brand new the
guys are waiting they don't know what's
happening and tasha walks in
yes and the reaction is everything you
could hope a group of 16 men would react
to seeing you
of course but at the same time i was
really really impressed with tasha
because
i feel like no one's guiding her like
she they just like through her and
they're like go where it's like chris
harrison you're supposed to walk
everyone through and like tell everyone
what's going on
and i felt like she handled it like a
champ that's like a very hard situation
to walk into she was so
charismatic and not awkward like she
commanded like the presence of the room
yeah and she just i don't know like she
just like was
super cool you know and i feel like not
most people would have just been like
right like awkward because it's an
awkward ass situation no but she took
charge and i feel like that immediately
made a lot of the guys really really
like her
she is just infectious like and that's
what they all keep saying they're like
can you imagine being there one of these
guys there was a girl
who didn't even know her their names
they've been moping around for two weeks
in like the same
hotel hotel like this the the
environment is really starting to like
depress me toxic even
and i can't even imagine how they're
feeling so can you just imagine like
this breath of fresh air who literally
takes the time to talk to everyone
and she has this like radiant smile
where i actually feel like it's gonna be
a confusing season because
i'm convinced that every person she
talks to like she's so in love with and
that's just because she's like a kind
person and she cares about people and
she just like wants to get to know
everyone like truly and then find the
best match for her
but she she's gonna break hearts because
everyone's gonna think that she's in
love with them because i think she's in
love with every person she talks to
yeah and the way the guys were
describing her after they first met her
like someone was like
she literally breathed new life into me
like i was really like feeling like what
am i doing here blah blah blah like she
just gave me a new life and
i was like wow like she just dazzles
yeah and you needed someone like that to
come and fill
this space because it was a negative
space yeah um i actually
really uh was was happy that they gave
her new guys because first of all
having 16 guys is just not enough and
it's not a fair place to start
and having 16 guys that were all
crushing on someone else literally
yesterday it's just not a fair place
and i actually think like every single
guy that got out of it there was only
like four or five that came the new ones
like they were all
so cute and they all have like real
potential and i know spencer is like
supposed to be a villain but like i
don't really see what he's done except
being annoying in basketball
like oh yeah he was being like a little
much but they said when he came into the
room he was being rude they definitely
produced definitely didn't let him say
how many people were coming so he had to
say
you'll see and he walked in and what did
he say to the guys like something he was
trying to break the ice he was like
what up like it wasn't they were very
sensitive they were but there was
another guy that came out noah with the
mustache yeah and i love him
he's cute but i feel like he gives me um
maybe because he's so cute he gives me
like he would be like confident vibes
yeah
i mean to walk around with a mustache
like that and still a cancer i'm like
you have to be a dick like because you
have to have
so much confidence yeah um and i also
really liked that after all those new
guys came
she canceled the rose ceremony like i
just feel like she's doing everything
the opposite of claire like everything
with these guys best interests she's
like half of you guys just got here i
haven't been able to talk to you and
like why would it be fair if you go home
i just feel like she's really doing this
the right way and i don't even know if
she's like intentionally trying to do
everything that claire didn't but like
the juxtaposition between the two girls
is just so clear
yeah it's definitely turned everyone's
frown upside down i feel like
i feel also like there's new life in
these guys
and i feel like we can all really
believe it and move forward not just
like
in the shadow of claire yeah um
so i feel like there were like a few
obvious connections
that guy who made her throw the coin and
saxty
i love him like i thought that was so
cute and i think she was like really
into like the corniness of it all you
know what's so funny it's like if she
lined up
if they lined up all the guys like i
feel like i would choose a bunch who i
think would be front runners and i think
we would all probably choose like the
same people
the people who it seems like she's
having the biggest connections with are
never are not any of the people that i
would have thought they're quiet
yeah like zach c um the guy she went on
the one on one right
he was so in the background when it was
claire season
yeah and now he's a major front-runner
um so then
i feel like she has interesting taste
in guys because jpg yes she had everyone
everyone
desired her in paradise and she chose
jpg who was really the quirkiest guy on
the beach she's different
she likes a quirky guy yeah so i think
it'll it will be interesting and i don't
think we'll really be able to predict
like the obvious choice like
spencer or noah who i think are like
really the most handsome like blake
moylan right isn't that his name like
the park ranger yes yeah no no there's
two blake m's so they had to use his
last name
so that's fine that's why he's like
playing that's so funny
um and then we were having this like
great time she canceled the rose
ceremony they're all just vibing
everyone's smiling and then cut two we
have to go back to dale and claire
right and to be honest my eyes were just
glazed over i didn't listen to anything
i guess the one thing they wanted to
make clear was that there was no
conversing or communicating before the
show and to be honest like
chris harrison was like did you lie to
bachelor nation and as a member of
bachelation
i kind of wish that they like did talk
before because it would make more sense
it would
i would understand claire's judgment a
little bit more but the fact that they
like swear
on her dad's grave she said that they
never spoke is like
but how like it would make more sense if
they did yeah i completely believe her
i think i i don't think she told one lie
in during her season i think if she had
been a little better at
lying or faking it she would have had a
longer season yeah you know um
and that that conversation between them
was really just a waste of time except
the very end when chris was like so
what's next and
they had two completely different
answers and they were just like talking
over each other she was like
babies marriage whatever whatever comes
first babies and tails like yeah maybe
we'll get married soon like
it was so awkward and it's just like
these two people
i just want to know when they filmed
that conversation like was it while
taisha was filming or was it
two weeks ago because there's been all
of these rumors that they're not
together right now
and that's the rumor that i just want to
clear up they seemed so happy like
genuinely happy when chris harrison sat
down with them
and even though it's been a complete
[ __ ]
claire i'm happy for you me too
know that i am and you know what i just
feel like
dale showed up
and that's what i've been waiting my
whole life for ladies
and gentlemen if the bar
is just showing up the bar is too low
i'm afraid i agree with my sister here
she said in the first episode and i said
it in our first afternoon recap and i'm
saying again like
i just think maybe she means more than
just showing up at this like
verbiage or just show up like no maybe
also like brush your teeth comb your
hair you know kind of be kind
of funny you know chivalrous i do think
i do think we're maybe setting the bar
too low and setting women back like if
that's the only i agree
like that's it no
no i was i don't accept that i was so
relieved when their thing was over like
i'm just like take me back
and then literally they went back and
they were at the pool and tasha like
literally bonded oh my god out of the
pool it was so sickening
i love her so much and i feel like
literally
someone literally they're honking for
tasha tasha
we hear you i know truck drivers america
they love tasha
um i was on my instagram story being
like with that dress that she wore
on the first night which was backless
like she just says this is like amazing
and not to be like weird
but like this amazing like body body and
it's like
it's like unlike anybody i've ever seen
like i know i sound so weird some girl
messaged me she's like i feel the exact
same way like i'm geisha for deja
and i'm like no literally saying like
she just has this like
radiance about her like physically
emotionally spiritually like she just
gives off this energy
and i feel like all the guys are like
really into her like so hard
so hard i hear exactly what you're
saying about um
her physique it's just it's really
special
and i hate to like make it about that
because we've met her and i actually
spoke to her yesterday because we were
dming and she was like she's just like
a lovely girl who's like smart and funny
and like that's why people just like
gravitate towards her but she also has
this like beautiful energy about her
totally and if you want to get to know
her more she came on the show a year ago
while we were in l.a she was
everything of the source oh my god she
just radiates and
i think a lot of people in general
radiate i think a lot of people on the
show radiate
but it's one thing to radiate in person
and it's another thing for that to come
through
truckers for taking i'm about to open
the window and [ __ ] scream stop
honking i'm going to open the window and
scream
oh
um so wait they go back to the pool and
they have this date
and i actually thought it was funny to
watch them all play uh
water basketball except things did get
like really weird for a minute between
spencer and of course i don't know riley
riley
um and it was really awkward like i felt
awkward watching like when he elbowed
him yeah tasha was like
but spencer was being annoying as [ __ ]
yeah it's not that serious
no i was honestly on team riley he's
like you're being a little [ __ ] like
you're gonna get elbowed in the mouth
like that is what happens
yeah were you so happy when tasha let
everyone come to the party
i literally wrote it down she let the
losing team come to the cocktail party
that's what i'm saying she is just this
breath of fresh air because she's the
opposite of claire like she really is
like an equal opportunity bachelorette
like anyone who is here gets an
opportunity to talk to me
and i just think it's so refreshing and
i didn't even realize that she did that
until they were all sitting and i'm like
wait
you lost same yeah i was like happy for
blake moylan because it had been another
date that he lost and he would have gone
home crying because like
he really thinks that like he is like
gonna win yeah even though like the
the green team the team that lost like
was the yellow belly losers like
blake has really just like fallen from
grace for me that's
what i tried that's what i was saying
last week like
he was a favorite no like literally i
thought he was like the cute
like i just thought he was a terrible i
thought he was like a benzy yeah
he has a terrible attitude now yeah and
then he was also on the team with that
guy who's the boy band manager who put
an okay kisser
he's a loser he is all over the place
yeah i don't know about him no i agree
so like when the green team lost i'm
like it's for the best like yeah
none of you had a real future here
anyways but she let them come which was
nice um
i just love her so much and then after
her one-on-one with that guy brendan who
she literally plucked out of obscurity
has he been here the whole time no i
think he was literally the one who
claire made a joke about during the rose
saying didn't i send you home last week
like
that's how random he was but their date
was
everything she just like makes everyone
feel special like i totally forgot that
she was married
and so when he was gonna tell her that
i'm like oh no i don't know where this
is going
you know what i actually wonder if
producers chose him for that first date
so that he would tell his backstory and
then she would tell her so that the
viewers would re
would know again if we didn't if they
didn't already know that that
is her history so we wouldn't have to
like have this whole package addressing
it or
coming out like later and i think that
actually is a pretty smart move
if that's what they did and then also it
happened to be like a really
great connection between the two of them
so cute and like
he's very quiet but he's not shy and i
like that she like acknowledge the fact
that like she's very loud and like
outgoing so like it's
probably better to have someone his
speed just to like balance each other
out and i thought their date was so cute
and i never i literally didn't even know
his name i never would have chosen him
for anything and oh i'm like oh they're
in love
right exactly also they messed up the
order of things for
i guess like continuity sake but um
jason went home he like went to her
house and was like i'm going home and
then that was before her one-on-one but
the outfit she was wearing was the one
she won her one-on-one so it's clear
that
he came to her house like either before
or after dinner um which i
actually like didn't bother me no
eventually
i was sad that was nice i was sad to see
him go and i i
also really liked her reaction where she
was like bummed to see him go to because
she was like
she's giving everyone she seems like a
really good guy and i
i thought maybe she would win him back
over but she doesn't want to be anyone's
second choice and i completely get that
yeah but like this guy is really unwell
like claire took him on that date and
like ripped open his heart and like made
him like diarrhea
everywhere like all of his feelings and
then she just like this is claire
right after making him like spill his
guts peace bye
like so [ __ ] rude and he's just left
in the dust he got no acknowledgement
from her like
some of the other guys who like wanted
claire to apologize or acknowledge like
they literally had never even met her
but he was the only other one who got
like a one-on-one and it was just like a
successful one-on-one the other one was
where oh my god he got sent home yeah
yeah
it was um it was good it was like i feel
like
what we said yesterday like cretaceous
so everything in the store like so much
so that the show was almost boring
yeah but this like situation at laquinta
is really starting to bum me out it's
anxiety
and i said this last week that i think
that the process um
is at a detriment because of the lack of
change of scenery you can't transport
yourself
you know that all of the guys are just
like literally they saw the fireworks
50 feet away and um if there's someone
there that you really like like you're
thinking about them like you can't like
compartmentalize the journey yeah and
i'm just like and it's only tasha week
one i know and i'm over
the setting i know do they leave at all
no because
it's a bubble right and tasha said if
you had told me last week that i would
be here did she quarantine
i hate to be coveted no no like i don't
i don't care i'm just kidding i
i think i don't know what she did
obviously like it's fine
but they made such a big deal about two
weeks before quarantine you really
need to watch them facetime we had to
watch the whole entire thing and then
just pops up so it's like wait she
ever they could have all just popped up
yeah no i'm not about to like start
questioning
how peop i believe everyone did what
they thought was best for themselves but
i'm just curious
yeah and i think that everything worked
out fine so
but yeah i saw some comments about that
too and it's like only because they
rammed it down our throats for an hour
about like the testing process and then
you just pop someone else up
agreed just be consistent just be
consistent be consistent
um so that is our bachelorette recap if
you're looking for more recap on the
bachelorette the season and just all of
the bachelor nation drama
we have a toast news network podcast
called the snatcher hosted by the
snatcher our sister
margot where they do weekly episodes
recapping all things going on bachelor
nation so check that out available on
spotify itunes all the places
um and now we're going to dive into deer
toasters which is our weekly advice
segment
if you ever want to write us in and you
can write about write in about
everything we try not to judge here it's
very hard sometimes
the email is dear toasters gmail.com
completely anonymously we will take out
people's names whatever you need
you can write us in and just hear from
your favorite gals about what's going on
in your life
hijacking claudia here's our first one
love you guys so much thank you for
making me laugh on my walk home every
weekday
so i started a nanny job a couple months
ago i watched a seven-year-old girl
stacy and i helped stacy with online
schooling she has an older sister
katie who's nine we used katie's ipad to
zoom as the parents requested when i
began the job
ever i just like feel like i feel like
it's going in that
direction like when it's like borrowing
technology it's like
always bad everything from a
nine-year-old i know
every morning when i go to get the ipad
from katie i met with so much attitude
eye rolling ignoring etc
at the end of the day katie interrogates
me asking why we were on specific apps
for specific amounts of time
i'm a very emotional girl and i don't
want to upset katie by taking her ipad
but that's what her parents wanted katie
hurts my feelings
i showed the parents the text katie sent
me interrogating me about the ipad usage
and they expressed how wrong that was of
her
and how they wanted me to be comfortable
doing whatever it's been a couple weeks
since that
talk and katie is being just as stingy
with the ipad again it makes me want to
quit lol what should i do okay this did
not go in the direction like
that i thought it would and i'm so
grateful yeah um
sounds like one of the kids who nanny's
for is like a little spoiled brat and
just tell her to get over it like
sometimes kids need a good
you know iron fist ruling yeah this
sounds like a real conflict between
campers and counselors
and i'll let you take this and sometimes
there's a camper in the bunk who's just
a little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and you know what you like i actually
that's so true i think there's a lot of
ways to go about it but i think
what i would try first is like literally
ignoring her
like the one who behaves well like give
her all of your love and attention
because i think at the end of the day
kids just want attention
and if she sees that her negative nancy
behavior is not going to attract
attention in fact it's the opposite
she might switch gears and try something
different
to get attention so i think like making
her jealous with your affection
is a good place to start um this is is
this like reminding you
like when you were an actual counselor
of like that camper who was a little
[ __ ] because i have a crazy story
oh cher there was when i was a i was a
junior counselor so i was like much
younger and so every junior counselor in
the bunk has to have like a real
counselor because like you can't just be
like a 16 year old watching these kids
so my like senior counselor the woman
she was above me she um she was such a
nice girl she was like from the middle
of nowhere
and it was her first summer like ever
counseloring anywhere and there was this
girl in the bunk and
i know her name i'll never say it she
was so ratty like she was
she was so obnoxious and she was so
spoiled
and she literally told the group leader
that
my co-counselor put hands on her so it
was like a huge thing i mean i
i literally didn't and she had a bruise
on her arm and we were like holy [ __ ]
literally the woman got fired like it
was a whole thing and literally the the
moment the counselor left it and said
the girl said she made it up wow and she
bit herself so that she would have a
bruise
oh my god that girl like it's insane
that's insane you could ruin someone's
life
100 and like for kids to like be that
manipulative it was actually dangerous
they were like literally in the sixth
grade like it was really scary
yeah wow um well good luck with stacey
and katie i do not envy your job
hey sisters love you both in the energy
you bring to my mornings
so i was with this guy for a little over
two years but we were never officially
together
during these years he would see other
girls i would know about it and it
wrecked me but i stuck around because
i'm young and stupid
about a month ago he invited me over and
i found a pair of panties in his bed ew
like clean up before you have guests
long story short we are no longer on
speaking terms and i've moved on because
i deserve better
but i cannot stop thinking about this
victoria's secret lace song that i found
in his sheets
i know exactly who they are and i'm
wondering if she left them there on
purpose so that i would find them
i know about this girl for a while but i
didn't think she knew about my
relationship with him
basically i knew about her but she
didn't know about me or so i thought
do we think that she just couldn't find
them and left with no panties on or do
we think that she left them on purpose
to claim her territory
but who just leaves their dirty
underwear in a guy's bed is this normal
i've completely moved on from the guy
but now i'm just curious about the
panties
any perspective is helpful thanks so
much xoxo i know where all my panties
are
that's a good question i mean it does
sound something like something like a
manipulative [ __ ] would do and like who
really
like who can go to work or like back to
wherever like without their panties
yeah no i could see someone doing this
intentionally even if it's not directed
at you like maybe she knows that
he is [ __ ] around and so like she
left a signal
to all the girls like this is my
territory
yeah i i don't know i wouldn't take it
personally but i would definitely
like exit the situation i would like
dismiss myself it's been two years that
is just like you don't need these people
and these panties in your life
yeah like two years of like your
precious you know youth is
it's unforgivable yeah you gotta get out
and the the time
and that this situation these panties
are like living rent-free in your mind
like that's also
unacceptable yeah so i definitely think
this girl was
claiming her territory for sure yeah but
not to you specifically because
if there's her and there's you there's
other [ __ ] too 100
and i think that you should excuse
yourself from
yeah from the situation these are not
your people
all right finally hi jackie and claudia
love the show and always love the advice
so i need your opinion
i was dumped yesterday on facetime by my
boyfriend we've been dating for three
months but it was serious both met each
other's families and friends within the
first three weeks
long-term future was discussed and
everything like that
well the problem comes that he's
actually been in florida for the last
three weeks
i went for the last week and he was
still there when he broke up with me
because shocker he hasn't he has decided
spur of the moment that he wants to move
to florida
we are both from baltimore so this isn't
a oh he moved around the corner kind of
thing
well i've things i have bought for him
for his house a gift i got for him for
christmas plus the money i just spent
flying
to and from florida to go see him am i
the pettiest person ever if i venmo
charge him for all these things
it totals over 500 and i would not have
done any of it without him if i knew he
was planning on randomly moving to
florida
i think it's okay but my sister says
it's bad karma please advise
quarantine love gone wrong oof that's
tough that is really tough
i i feel like you're whatever you decide
to do if you do venmo him which
you're totally justified in doing like
you are prolonging this breakup like
yeah then it just gets messier and they
talk more and like talk it out and fight
and it's just like
if you want to get out of this like just
maybe eat the money i think again like
you need to extricate yourself from this
situation it sounds like you got really
invested really quickly
and i think that you know putting a
price
on all of the things just like
continuous communication like keeps your
feelings open whereas like this needs to
end right now so
if you and i liked what i think what
your sister said about the karma being
interesting because i wouldn't have said
that i just
would have said like i guess maybe it's
like petty but 500
is a lot of money she's not but i do
think that you just have to sometimes
let like just let it all go you know
like all of it the emotions
the i like the things like but if it
just
if you need the money back like
definitely ask him
but if you're doing it to be petty and
you don't like need the money to live
i might con reconsider i think it might
be better for you to just like
extricate yourself as quickly and
swiftly as possible because it sounds
like you've been through a lot
yeah um and like this is honestly i
would i would be grateful that like this
relationship only lasted three months
and like you didn't waste that much time
with this guy so just like
let's wash our hands of it and onto
greener pastures yeah i just i
i agree with that um so those were our
deer toasters again you can always write
us in the email is dear toasters at
gmail.com
and if you have written us in the last
few months and you want to update us on
whether or not you followed our advice
or whether or not you thought we were
stupid
write us back again dear toasters with
update in the subject line and we will
read your update if you want us to
online um that's all she wrote anything
you want to say before we wrap up
oh no um i will see you tomorrow we have
so much tv tomorrow will be like a
really exciting show salt lake city
oc housewives cma wow how are we going
to fit it all in i don't know if i might
just watch a cma award like
uh performances on youtube like okay
but that's all we got thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify insist your public radio iranic
sports all the places where you've
listened to podcast find us more each
other's living funds everybody beautiful
signing it's where we are
we hope you have an amazing day happy
hump day hump someone you love and we'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
you